there's a lot of people that
are concerned
that the
fisa vaccine by the way of which i took
two shots
no booster yet
is unsafe
what do you say to people
that say that
no they should not
fear something like that it's completely
wrong there is no
medical product in the history of
humanity that have been tested as much
as this vaccine has been administered to
hundreds of millions of people
and because
of the importance of covid they have
been scrutinized those people
constantly right now healthcare
authorities are looking for every single
signal around the world of people that
they got the vaccine and try to see if
it is vaccine related or not
there are electronic medical records
that will tell us
when and what happened to a person when
he did got the vaccine
and
we know now
more we have so high certainty that it
is so safe
exactly as the datasheet
says about this vaccine more than any
other product
they should not be afraid of something
like that and they should not listen
to
information but it is misinformation but
it is spread on purpose
well
i don't like the word misinformation
because
you know again back to the soviet union
anyone who opposes the state is
spreading misinformation
so you can basically call anything
misinformation that's the unfortunate
times we live in
is
you can call anyone you can basically
call anybody a liar and say i'm the sole
possessor of the truth
and uh just no offense to me just
because you wear a tie doesn't mean
you're
any more likely to be in the possession
of the truth than anyone else so i
wouldn't disagree with that at all
i don't think that's somebody who's not
wearing it
and as you can people can see that i'm
not wearing a tie and you are
but um it's not about
being able those that they have the
power
to
to impose on the others the stigma
that
you what you are saying is
misinformation
but there are few things that the
society we have accomplished and science
is one of them and
data
is
and analytics of data is another one
and to say that
something
which is highly scientific by people
that they are not scientists
i
i think that it is not what you are
describing what used to happen in soviet
union or in any other autocratic
regime in the world right now but i
definitely do think
that uh the scientists the public
science communicators i've listened to
over covet really disappointed me
because they have not
spoken with empathy they haven't
sufficiently in my view have put their
ego aside and really listen to people
yes people that don't have a phd people
have not
really
you know
maybe not even taken like a biology
course in college or something like that
but
still they they they have children they
they worry they fear
they don't know who to trust they don't
know if they should listen to the ceo of
pfizer who might have other incentives
in mind who might just care about money
and nothing else and so
they just use common sense and they ask
questions and i think to them talking
down to them as if they're not
intelligent so on is something
scientists have done
almost like rolled their eyes and that
disappoints me because i think that's
kind of what's is the source of division
look humility is a virtue yes and uh yes
the fact that you're educated doesn't
mean that you are having either humility
or empathy
or you have good
human qualities this was never
and will never be
a metric of judging this type of virtues
those that they do this
they're wrong and actually
they
they are not
doing good service to the public health
because they are undermining people
aren't stupid they see if you are not
be
respecting them and if you're not
respecting their need to learn because
that affects their health the health of
the mother of the kids so i fully agree
with you that we should be
very
patient to explain again and again and
again
what is happening and the vast majority
of the people that they don't get
vaccinations right now is because
they're afraid it's not for any other
reason it's not that they have a an
agenda what i'm saying it is there is a
small number of people
that they have make business
for them
to
[Music]
profit from this anxiety i'll give you
an example
i have been arrested by fbi this is what
someone wrote i i read it i laughed i
mean
okay
this is where they take it there was a
reason why they wrote that the files you
always arrested fbi because they want to
create doubts in the minds of the people
that they're afraid and say look if fdi
arrested him likely i will not do the
vaccine but i laughed
a week later
the wife of the philoso
died
there is a picture in the in this
website of my wife
someone sends to me
now i'm pissed i'm not laughing i try to
find my kids
to tell them if you read something mom
is fine don't worry
then i remember that she has
very old parents back in greece we start
calling them to making sure because you
know that that will be picked up by
greek newspapers and they will
publish it okay they are those people
that wrote these things they know very
well that my wife didn't die and died
because she she was vaccinated right
so this is the narratives that they are
on purpose
forming
to profit
from
the stress and
the anxiety of good people and that's
something i have to kind of people that
listen to this that kind of dialed
institutions
i do also want to say that
there's quite a few folks
who realize they can make money
from
[Music]
saying
the man is lying to you
the government is lying to you
it's all corrupt
it's all a scam
big farmer is lying to you they're
manipulating you
i'm surprised that how much money can be
made with that
and it's sad so you have to just as
people use their common sense
to uh be skeptical when listening to
politicians and powerful figures they
should be skeptical
to also when listening to sort of the
the conspiracy theorists or not even the
conspiracy theorists but people who
raise questions about institutions
think
think on your own think critically with
an open mind
that everyone can be manipulating
you but also everybody has the capacity
to do good
and i think science in this pure form
not when entangled institutions
is a beautiful thing
and in the hands of many companies it is
a beautiful thing at scale
you